[Music]
well that does it time for the purge for
the next 12 hours all crime is legal I'm
so excited this is gonna be the perfect
night what do you have planned looting
murder what no I'm gonna pirate episodes
of great british baking show and then
tinker with the YouTube algorithm and
heck if there's time we can even maybe
steal the recipe for diet coke and be in
bed by 11:00 that does sound like the
perfect night
it does clink
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that strives to purge every
ounce of fun and whimsy from all the
movies that you love today we're taking
a stab at the purge franchise which if
you haven't seen is actually really
interesting in terms of premise it's set
in an alternate future where Americans
are entitled to 12 hours of purging
every year starting at 7:00 p.m. every
March 21st all crime in the u.s. is
legal lasting until 7:00 a.m. the
following morning commencing at the
siren any and all crime including murder
will be legal for 12 continuous hours
and as you might expect the purge
franchise really digs in exploring all
sorts of creative crimes that people
might choose to commit if there were
indeed no laws for the night just
kidding it is just a bunch of killing
murder murder murder sure there's a bit
of vandalism and looting sprinkled in
for flavor but come on you're telling me
that all crime is legal for 12 hours and
nobody is using that opportunity to do
anything interesting with it where's all
your creativity people rigged gambling
hacking insider trading why are we not
following the people who are trying to
make themselves filthy stinking rich
with all this focus on murder and petty
looting you're wasting such a cool
premise you have 12 hours each year to
change your life or heck improve the
lives of your family friends society
itself and you use it all to smash a few
windows big big picture here people so
that loyal theorists is our question
today not how to survive the purge but
how you win the purge what is the best
use of that 12-hour window because let's
face it
what started as a pretty wacky film
series is starting to feel more and more
possible every day and we need to be
prepared you know what I'm gonna be
honest when I first embarked on this
thought experiment I assumed that
developing the perfect purge strategy
would be pretty darn easy all I had to
do is figure out what high-yield crimes
would be safely carried out in one night
hire some hackers or whatever and then
profit but when you actually start
thinking through the logistics of this
stuff things actually get a lot more
complicated because remember when all
crime is legal it's legal for every
one that becomes a two-way street say
for instance you figure out a way to
cheat a casino and you want to cash in a
few loaded dice or a stacked deck in
your hand it sounds like a fun and
profitable way to spend the purge night
right no problem
well yes big problem for those 12 hours
not only can you cheat the casino the
casino is legally allowed to rigged the
game against you and with them
controlling the cards the deck is
definitely stacked against you here's
another one say you want to rob a bank
vault though you're gonna need
associates for your heist but make sure
that you trust those guys since you know
you can always pull a Dark Knight and
just off you at the end of the evening
and take the loot for themselves it's
actually something that we see in the
purge movies remember how well it works
when criminals work with other criminals
in those films not super great but then
again that might be the least of your
worries considering that the bank guards
themselves are suddenly legally able to
straight-up murder you again it's no
rules for everyone when developing the
perfect purge strategy you also have to
remember that the purge is a yearly
event so you don't want to be committing
a crime that's gonna screw someone over
and then be traced back to you since a
year from now it's gonna leave a big old
target on your back market manipulation
insider trading
identity theft embezzlement these can
all be traced back to you because
they're being done online committing
these sorts of crimes during the purge
doesn't really offer you that much
additional cover than any other day of
the year sure the US government might
choose not to prosecute you since your
crime occurred during that window of
opportunity but does that really matter
when you've stolen a ton of money from
presumably wealthy well-connected
powerful people come next year's purge
you could find yourself at the receiving
end of some extremely well-funded
vigilante justice or to demonstrate one
last example of the complicating factors
of the purge say you want to spend that
time counterfeiting US currency or you
have a bunch of counterfeit currency and
you want to use it great it's a plan
that literally is printing money but you
spending that cash is actually gonna
happen outside of the purge window
meaning that once again you're a
criminal
tried to deposit it in a bank too bad
you can't it's too late in the day and
honestly the bank doesn't have to do it
legally they're not responsible for that
and even if you could do any of this
there's one other layer that we have to
take into account here sure
national laws may be suspended but what
about international laws
US laws may turn a blind eye for 12
hours but international laws woe to the
1929 Geneva Convention may the
counterfeiting of any currency illegal
in every country so even if you didn't
technically do anything illegal in the
US you'd still be breaking the law in a
ton of other countries income 7:00 a.m.
the next morning - USS extradition
treaties are back in effect
international money laundering tax
evasion schemes big old notes there - so
at this point I feel like I should pause
and offer an apology - James demonaco
the writer director and producer of the
purge before I began researching this
topic I figured the purge franchise was
well I thought it was kind of dumb fun
yeah absolutely but definitely dumb just
mindless popcorn fodder
I'll admit it the fact that all the
purge characters pretty much stuck to
was murder just kind of felt cheap it's
like they weren't behaving like real
people would in the scenario and instead
we're just doing a bunch of fun to watch
crimes for no other reason that they
were in a violent horn it felt like lazy
writing and I was oh so ready to poke
holes in the wishy-washy legalese of it
all with hypotheticals like let if you
shoot someone at 6:59 but they don't die
until seven oh one who the government
still prosecute you then or what if
you're caught in possession of stolen
property the day after the purge what
then but what I came to realize is that
it's all fairly simple none of that
matters whether or not the government's
gonna prosecute you for crimes that
occur outside that 12 hour window hardly
matters because the true judgment and
the true threat is ultimately coming
from your fellow man the people that
you've wronged will have a chance to get
even on March 21st the following year or
there's always the international
authorities who'd like to get even as
well so to truly win the purge we need a
highly profitable crime that can be over
and done with
within that 12 hour window a crime that
isn't governed by international law and
doesn't rely on us screwing over other
people or leave us open to the reverse
or if we are taking advantage of someone
it can't be left alive to know about it
so at this point you're probably
starting to wonder if there's any crime
out there that won't get you targeted in
a future purge and the answer is yeah
sure there's tons of crimes that you can
commit that would benefit society
filling pot
without a permit trespassing on a
private beach to pick up trash
these are victimless crimes they're not
gonna make it rich and if we're aiming
for the perfect perch well we need it
all but what what is a victimless crime
that could benefit society and get you
rich at the same time theorists I
thought about this for a long time I
looked deep inside of myself for a
solution and wouldn't you know it I
found that solution there deep within me
in fact I found lots of solutions deep
within me literally that's right I'm
talking organ harvesting consider this a
legal healthy human heart is valued at a
million dollars a million dollars for
your heart and that is just one organ
now on any other night of the year human
organs wouldn't be readily available and
you wouldn't be legally allowed to sell
them but guess what on purge night it's
no rules just right just like an Outback
Steakhouse
we know from well pretty much every
purge movie but let's call out purge
election-year that a whole bunch of dead
bodies just lie around in the streets
until 7:00 a.m. the next morning we see
this very explicitly as lenient on spend
the purge driving around in an armored
ambulance carefully considering who'd
help but instead of focusing on the
living what if instead we chose to focus
on the dead good Laney and Donna found
something that we could capitalize off
of I'm thinking so cuz we could use that
same armored ambulance idea to collect
the dead bring you and bring those
freshly killed perjures to hospitals or
at the very least our gang of waiting
doctors and nurses where the organs in
the body could then be harvested by
trained medical professionals in proper
facilities now normally this would be
totally illegal commercial harvesting
and selling of body parts is illegal in
all countries except Iran but on purge
night those concerns go out the window
and you see these organs are incredibly
valuable in every sense of that word in
the US alone there are more than a
hundred and thirteen thousand candidates
waiting for transplants and many are
willing to pay whatever it takes to get
access to that life-saving organ which
has in turn created a black market for
some of the stuff this is especially
true for kidney transplant
humans are born with two but they only
need one so the selling of your second
kidney to people who need it is
something that really does exist out
there in the world and the idea of using
the recently dead as organ donors isn't
a new idea either people can sign up to
be organ donors for after they die and
in China inmates executed on death row
were historically used as organ donors
so let's talk brass tacks how much is
one dead body and purge not gonna net us
well unfortunately we have to discount
some of the most valuable organs right
out of the gate a heart is normally
useless after death so we're gonna have
to kiss that million dollars I mentioned
earlier goodbye the liver also breaks
down pretty quickly after cardiac arrest
so we're not gonna be able to pawn that
one either some relatively small ticket
items will last a bit longer like the
skin which collectively might be around
$5,000 the corneas in your eye will be
worth significantly more if undamaged at
about $20,000 and those kidneys that I
mentioned before they're going for about
two hundred and sixty two thousand
dollars not too shabby for an organ we
got two of but the real big-ticket item
here is something that goes deeper than
all those bone marrow bone marrow is by
far the most valuable substance by
weight in the human body has incredible
$23,000 per gram per gram and the human
body oh boy does it have a lot of the
stuff the average full-grown human male
is walking around with about 2.6
kilograms of bone marrow in their body
that is nearly 60 million dollars of
bone marrow just sitting there in your
chair right now and here some of you
thought that you weren't worth that much
so this then begs the obvious question
of why isn't everyone rushing down to
the hospital right now to sell off a
tiny piece of their body and buy a new
house or something well in most states
it's illegal in California for instance
you can be compensated up to $3,000 for
the procedure so there is an upper limit
to what you could be earning legally
from this sort of stuff and you see for
as huge as some of these numbers are
that's the overall rub these are the
real prices of these organs million
dollars for a harsh quarter million for
a kidney a bunch for bone marrow but in
reality if you were to sell this stuff
they're not netting that high of a price
according to medical transcription
estimates the average price of a dead
human body is likely
be more around $550,000 still half a
million dollars for each person that you
pick up off the street
not too bad on purge night those streets
are paved in gold fleshy cadaverous
recently murdered gold and that my
friends is the recipe for the perfect
purge like I said in the US alone
there's currently over a hundred
thousand people waiting for organs but
only about 14 thousand organs get
donated every year but with this plan a
there's no victim because they were
already dead in the street be you and
your team of medical professionals are
actually working to help save some of
the people on that hundred thousand
person wait list and see harvesting and
selling organs to hospitals or on the
black market or whatever you end up
doing in that 12-hour window could net
you a ton of cash maybe as much as five
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
body that you pick up see most people
might use the purge to settle vendetta's
or enrich themselves financially even
are these selfish people really doing
the purge right the purge is an
opportunity to give the gift of life to
otherwise hopeless people by
circumventing society's red tape for a
connoisseur that's looking to purge
perfectly those 12 hours aren't just an
opportunity to get rich it's an
opportunity to make a difference and
that is doing the purge right that my
friends is the perfect purge but hey
that's just a theory
oh film theory and one last thing
actually being a blood or bone marrow
donor really does help save lives heck
I'm gonna go out on a limb here and tell
you that I'm personally signed up to be
an organ donor for when I die I mean my
eyes are terrible site wise but if my
corneas can help someone see for the
first time or repair damage to their eye
then great awesome I'm paying it forward
even after I'm done living and bone
marrow is a truly life-saving substance
used in treatments of a lot of cancers
stuff like Leukemia Lymphoma sickle-cell
disease
aplastic anemia well it may not be
possible to sell your bone marrow in our
non purge world you can donate it and in
turn make a real difference today so
check out be the match.com or ask your
doctor the next time you're in it for a
checkup
how you
can make our world a little less like
the one in the purge donating things
like bone marrow blood make a huge
difference and you know what today we
can all stand to be a little bit more
compassionate to one another you know
help make our world a little less like
the one that we see in that fictional
universe man who knew that I'd get so
sappy after an episode dedicated to
ripping out the organs of other people
in the purge and profiting off of them
anyway that's the theory hand cut up
those dead bodies so you can go sell
them for some big bucks in the purge
world my friends sorry I couldn't stay
serious for too long to end with some
tongue-in-cheek cynical statement but
seriously go donate blood looking to do
it right now actually looking for a good
place in the area surprisingly difficult
to find